um depends and this is for the men too
you guys can yeah it depends on their
situation
that depends on what I mean the
situation is there's no doubt okay that
yeah
he isn't there it might not have been
the choice you know so okay let's let's
take me I don't have kids let's say I'm
35. would it be selfish in this
situation I'm 35
and I no prospects it's just you know my
DMs are a desert it's horrible
and so I say you know what I I want a
child so I'm gonna go to the IVF clinic
and I'm gonna do it or I'm gonna I don't
I don't know I don't know the science
behind it the I don't think it's selfish
but I think you need to think about you
know what can you offer the child can
you because you want your child to grow
up in certain conditions right so do you
have enough money to provide for the
child do you have maybe have a male
figure around you
um maybe your brother your dad that can
still support your child as a man so you
don't think it's selfish to expect that
out of them no because again then before
you have a child I would have locked
that in I would have already like
thought about these things do I have
money for this do I have men around me
that can support my child that can offer
that guidance if I don't then I'm then I
may not have a child because
again it's alive you want to offer
someone the best life that you can give
right if I'm not in that position I'm
not going to have a child okay what do
you guys think well you said no
prospects so I'd say that's kind of
selfish
that's what you really bring into the
table is like oh as a soul person you're
not really bringing like the love and
the support you might be able to to a
certain extent but by yourself that's
hard like I wouldn't really want to wish
that on someone okay I think if it's a
choice
for you to bring a child into this world
by yourself and then look after the
child by yourself I think that is
selfish because
um what about you China yeah I'll just
I'll just waiting to see if anyone's
gonna say it wasn't selfish but yeah
it's incredibly selfish to to bring a
child into the world and do it by by
those types of means yeah okay
I feel like
in general it's kind of selfish even
though you mentioned Pearl earlier you
said that having not having a kid was
selfish I think like having a kid is
inherently quite selfish let's take a
moment to think about the world that we
live in today let's think about politics
let's talk about financials let's think
about everything that comes into being
an adult in the world that we live in
today the lowest rates of poverty ever
in human history yeah but human history
is [ __ ] first of all like let's think
about it comparatively I mean if you
genuinely really genuinely want children
of course you can have children but if
you're having children because you full
actually need to that's different what's
wrong with the like the world today is
great especially in the west it is
better than it's ever been but it's
really awesome it's phenomenal so were
your parents selfish for having you
they're rubbing my face all the time no
Mom's asking you no I think they are how
many siblings do you have I have two so
there's three of you so your parents
were incredibly selfish for having you
guys and the thing is I feel like my
parents do have a lot of regret in terms
of having children especially so so you
wish she wasn't alive do you feel like
you feel like you don't want to be alive
that's not what I'm saying because
before a fetus is born they don't even
know what life is that's what I'm asking
you said it's incredibly selfish and
you're saying but I'm saying you come
from a family of three
um so do you consider your life to be
selfish I'm not gonna say on [ __ ]
camera that I wish I was dead there's no
need to swear we're just having a
conversation
but no but you're swearing the
conversation something is quite rude I
wasn't trying to be rude I was just
swearing like I normally taught I know
but it's not quite we'll see okay so
when you when you meet someone you've
never met somebody for the first time to
swear it when you speak to that person
with considered to quite rude so we're
on a platform and we're talking to like
a thousand thousand people every time
that you're using towards that it's like
it's [ __ ] Ruth I'm not gonna lie
to me okay
I've just literally just spoke I haven't
done anything you're beating her guys
have I raised my voice no bro have I
said anything derogatory wait hold on a
second wait you're stopping me it's
really rude
how much that she's alive no I asked her
a question I asked a question I asked a
question you keep interrupting so
nothing about my turn so the problem so
what we seem to find is when men speak
and when we speak directly we always get
women that try to speak to us about a
tone there's nothing wrong with my
tongue I haven't raised it she literally
just said it so could you just could you
check your friend put oh check the lady
next year and say there's nothing wrong
with his home you can check your
direction no but the thing is no but the
thing is directly if you want to no but
the thing is I am and everyone now
you're raising your voice that's the
time so what you're doing is yeah you're
gaslighting the situation this is what
you women this is not what no no no no
no this is like yes
no no let me teach you I think I think
the question was a bit wow but that's
why we're on a podcast the question is
so what you guys are doing again you
guys are stopping the man from speaking
I tried several times on this platform
to speak oh now I'm waiting not you but
what you've done is first of all you
guessed like that situation by saying
about my tone I didn't raise my tone I
didn't speak
see what you're doing again see guys
guys so so this is a so this is a good
platform so I want a super chats to look
at look at this this one this is an
example of gaslighting I simply asked
the question because you said it was
selfish for um for people from having
children right now so I asked her do you
consider it to be selfish for your
parents that had you as a child
um she was you know thinking about it
that's fine I had to think about it but
she swore at me so I've never met this
lady it's the first time I met her and
she sworn at me so I just said could you
please answer me on a platform what
you've then said to me is about my tone
if anything I would actually be quiet in
my right if someone swore at me so bro
what she actually his responders just
said she's naturally swears anyway so so
as much as you're in your willing your
rats to be offended by what she said
because you don't know her you don't
know yourself your own person you have
your boundaries okay so you're allowed
to feel the way you feel
do you think the world owes you any
understanding so if you've never met
someone in your meeting for the first
time do you think the world owes your
understanding to be like I can just if
I'm blind at you do you think I owe you
understanding
no you've never been to East London
she just said that to almost like
to comfort you like it's all right I
didn't mean it so let's use this example
right guys so this is an example right
there's nothing wrong so there's nothing
wrong with my tone I haven't raised my
tone I haven't pointed at you I haven't
shouted at you okay okay no no he didn't
stop yes it's easy it's easy I mean he
was doing she she's like he did yeah she
I didn't so so you know what it is you
know what it is I find it
so I don't I don't want to do this Pearl
but I'm going to say this as a black man
and I'm going to do that I find it this
is this is a scenario that that we find
ourselves in I haven't done anything I
haven't shouted at you I haven't been
aggressive to you I haven't sworn at you
but yet you no but what yet you have
continued to talk about my tone you've
tried to create an image of me Perpetual
image of me on screen which is not that
I was sworn to on live on the air that's
all I said was can you please not sweat
no no it's fine but we're not talking
about you now what we're talking about
is her gaslighting a scenario and she's
spoken about about the tone she's trying
to act like I've been aggressive to her
guys the super chats and everything will
let you know because I really haven't
done it you guys have jumped on top of
me but it's fine I'm ready for this
let's switch the situation
if we switch the rate they're not the
races the genders here if a girl says
that to a guy could you please not swear
at me it wouldn't be a thing and like
and that's the thing whenever men have
standards they're ashamed for having
standards constantly yeah it wasn't a
thing in the first place he said I swore
at him I'm swearing as I talk the way I
talk occasionally I'm actually a [ __ ] or
[ __ ] too bye mistake like I'm just
having a conversation because I feel
like a little bit more comfortable if
you don't want me to swear at you that's
completely fine it was quite simple I
simply said and I just made you aware of
it I didn't actually get at you I just
simply said could you please not swear
at me you don't know you weren't aware
of it but what happens from there I
can't believe what's happened it's just
simply a man saying please don't swear
at me and you guys have used it as a
situation to Gaslight instead about my
tone and even if I did lose lose my rag
a little bit why are you swearing at a
man that you've never met before in the
first time on a platform is very
disrespectful he was not swear no no no
no no right now this is not even about
this no no no because I'm not actually
offended by what you said I just simply
said you could please not swearing me
said okay that's cool what she's then
gone on to do is create a whole separate
scenario now and I want to know why have
you done that I was sticking up for her
because I felt like the question just
was a little insensitive to say that
just the way it was so you don't think I
was I was in my right to ask her
considering she said no not about the
swearing I understand no no about the
swearing she said that I just said being
selfish right so I just said do you
consider your existence and your
siblings existence to be selfish based
upon the question that she put out there
I simply just gave a counter question it
wasn't the way it was how was it worded
I'm sorry no no no no because this is an
example no we're not going to do this
because what you women do is you man you
might guess like you guys gas like men
and then we when we actually want to
prove a point you're like let's move it
on we're not going to move it on I want
to know no because I want to know what
what led to the point where you can
start saying about my tone and start a
disrespect what led to it what did I say
to her you said to her about do you wish
that you weren't alive or something
along them lines it was worded that way
and I just thought oh that's a little
bit too much but that came after the
fact that she said she considered it to
be selfish
I do think the question was a bit whoa
and we're all in that
after what she had said I wouldn't be
like why are you asking me that it makes
sense because even me I was kind of like
yeah do you not want to be here
sometimes I have my days so
so I don't think personally but I can
see why someone else might be a bit like
I don't know you whoa do you understand
so even if she threw in the little the
little [ __ ] or whatever
I was a bit taken about that you took it
okay okay
let's go stop stop we're gonna we're
gonna we're gonna stop stop you just did
it again okay we're gonna move on um do
you guys back road you guys think it's
selfish to
um get IVF treatment
um and become choose to be a single
mother go ahead
in the corner yeah
yeah okay you think it's selfish what
about you
Sam why people would do it but
yeah just denying without a father in
the pictures
oh it's not fair yeah it's selfish
because ultimately every woman will try
to locate a man that can fill that
further figure or teach certain things
that the partner or the husband or
whatever would have taught if they were
within a union as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible